[Music]
kevin i'm concerned you went to the
doctor this weekend is everything okay
uh no it's not okay okay do you want to
talk about it yeah let me just tell you
really quickly what happened
this is how i would sit if i was on a
baseball team by the way
[Laughter]
what happened was um i tore my bicep
muscle a couple years ago in this arm
yes i remember that yeah playing
basketball not professionally
and
[Laughter]
and i and then um last friday i tore
this muscle this one i had repaired a
couple years ago and now i tore this one
lifting a couch
and um and i haven't had surgery for a
long time and i went to the hospital and
they prep you they tell you what's going
to happen and the guy said would you
mind walking to the operating room
and i've never heard of this before but
i guess you know what with the economy
they're cutting corners here and there
you know
and uh you walked to the emergency
operating yeah yeah not no gurney yeah
walking
and um but i told the guy i said that's
all the help i'm giving i'm not going to
be handing tools and things like that
and i get to the operating room and i
push open the door and it's freezing in
there they keep it really cold because
in case you don't make it they don't
want you stinking up the room
and uh
funny now it doesn't take that it
doesn't happen that quickly that you
start to stink oh believe me it does
yeah all right i don't know what you're
into
you could stink when you're alive
that is true you don't even have to do
that that is true
i'm sorry i side i decide
and that's andy andy andy that's right
um
so it's cold in there yeah so i think
barack oh no i'm talking about the
hospital
um
so surgery yeah so i'm running the
operating room yeah it's cold and i see
the operating table and they uh it's all
lit up and they added wings onto it you
know because they're doing my arm so it
looked like a crucifix and that usually
never ends well from what i've read
and uh and i climb up on the table and
you know it's so surreal because you're
doing all this by yourself yeah and they
give you that michael jackson medicine
and boom you're out like that you know
that is that is the actual that's the
drug they use is it puts you out yeah
and then you wake up and then it's all
done you're ready to rehearse are you
ready to perform yeah yeah
and so um
i had to be in philadelphia like three
days later and this was a little more
involved than i thought you know i'm
like taking painkillers and it's in a
sling and i call the surgeon i said is
it okay to fly you know the altitude and
stuff i don't know pressure yeah uh and
he said to me he goes you know what
there's a good chance of a slight chance
he said of a blood clot but no more than
the plane crashing those are the same
percentages he said
he said you have something to say hey i
know
he said you should get up walk up and
down the aisle like every 15 minutes um
and that's a long flight from la to
philadelphia that's like a five hour
flight 7 with the walking yeah
but he just wanted you to keep moving
you keep the blood flowing sure you know
so i did that and
i didn't know if i was doing that to
keep the plane from crashing or from
getting a blood clot you know what i
mean i didn't know what the doctor knew
right he just told you to do it you're
doing it yeah and people either thought
i was a terrorist or they thought yes
kevin we saw you when you came on the
planet
[Laughter]